rescue workers are battling to reach 19
cars trapped in a flooded tunnel in
Chengdu South Korea
it's not clear how many people are in
the vehicles
there's some of the thousands of people
who've had their lives disrupted after
three days of heavy rains the torrential
downpour triggered landslides sparing
property in many parts of the country
in the central Jason District a dam
overflowed causing power cuts and
damaging roads and bridges
thousands of people have been forced to
leave their homes to seek shelter and
medical treatment
but more bad weather is expected
it's the peak of South Korea's Summer
monsoon season and meteorologists have
forecast heavy rain until Wednesday
they've warned the severe weather poses
a grave danger to the public
Barbara angopa Al Jazeera